hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the serious science of schmutz
deep sequencing the built environment I
am Robert Castellanos of lab moves and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars contributing to the
advancements of science through content
sharing capabilities lab roots is a
powerful advocate in amplifying global
networks and communities for more
information please visit lab routes comm
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by tapping on the
Q&A box which can be found on the Q&A
box on the lower left hand of the screen
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we possibly can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would like
to now introduce today's guest speaker
dr. Scott Kelly dr. Kelly received
training and microbial diversity and
mechatronics from one of the founders of
this research field dr. Norman pace as a
postdoctoral fellow of the University of
Colorado he was also trained in bio
mattox by one of the earliest and most
influential bio meditations dr. gary
store
since that time he has published 53
papers related to borrow microbial metal
jonnicks and bio from attics in many
influential journals his studies include
both DNA sequence based analysis of
microbial diversity of numerous
different environments including the
built environment human gut Micro Micro
rubem habitations numerous papers on
biking bioinformatics software tools and
novel analytical approaches to data
analysis dr. Kelly is a pioneer in the
application of molecular NGS analysis a
microbial diversity in the built
environment humans in industrialized
society spend greater than ninety
percent of their time indoors and we
know precious little about the indoor
microbial communities along with dr.
Norman pace he published the first paper
that used cultural independent methods
to study an indoor environment namely
shower curtain biofilms since then he
has studied a broad range of indoor
environments including Mike Mike O'Brien
contaminated hospital pool air and
surface and neonatal intensive care
units offices airplanes daycare
facilities and restrooms these papers
are well cited and help inspired the
Alfred P sloan foundations microbes in
the built environment program I would
now like to turn it over to dr. Kelly
for his presentation
good morning everybody good morning
everybody from Sandy ate a big meriting
everybody Scott Kelly from talking from
san diego or it still is morning so i'm
gonna be talking about as robert said
the serious science of schmutz and
deeply deep sequencing in the built
environment and please forgive me in
this a little bit awkward at times the
first time i've done an interactive
presentation like this and I'll do my
very best hopefully I won't mess it up
to them so I've been working on as
Robert sedative and working on
microbiology of the built environment
and meta genomics since but since 2001
and with dr. Nora page we published the
we published the first study of culture
independent study of the built
environment which means we were using
sequence analysis rather than culturing
on a plate and I'll talk to you why that
might be important later on but
essentially we were the first study to
really explore built environment
diversity and since then I published a
lot of other papers in the field is
grown tremendously since that time so
let's get started all right so I really
like this quote from a paper by diesel
at all and it's also with dr. Norman
pace the humans we move through a sea of
microbial light that is seldom perceived
except in the context of bacterial of
potential disease and decay so it's all
around us it's all in us we have 100
trillion microbes in and on our bodies
10 times more than our actual cells they
almost no we know nothing about them
practically nothing about them except
the ones that actually cause disease
indicate that we actually know about so
there's a lot more than we need to
discover and you know even if we could
culture all of them which we can't it
would take forever to actually get
through them all so really by applying
molecular methods we've expanded our
really expanded our understanding beyond
the culture
work and we've also this also includes
the built environment which as you'll
see is increasingly important in human
health and just in human existence so
the reasons the study endure our built
environment microbiology are here's a
few reasons first of all we spend not
westernized or industrialized countries
spend just about 90 on estimated ninety
percent of our time indoors and that
includes increasing amount of the what
is that what used to be the third world
is now the industrialized world I was
recently in China and I was in the city
of Shenzhen and in the last 30 years has
gone from a population of 300,000 to 17
million people so more and more people
all around the world are moving into
cities and spending all the time indoors
and I think something like children in
the United States spend on the order of
11 hours a day in front of their screens
so that's the average and that's an
incredible amount of time to spend in
door so you could really say that the
indoor built environment is now the new
human habitat disease transmission is
also important aspect there's a large
debate and maybe important some inert
surfaces in the spread of microbes we
know that you can pick up a lot of
microbes when you can go to the hospital
including antibiotics distant ones but
the question is how long where are they
how long they are hacked and surfaces
can we move them from place to place and
how many opportunistic infections are we
going to have on these so it's an open
debate that i believe and i'll show you
that i think that culture independent
methods can really or deep sequencing
methods it really shed some light on
this and it come out in combination with
with other studies can really help us
understand how their things were moving
around and what that means for help up
again opportunistic infections there's
something on the order for 100,000
deaths per year in the united states
alone they come from being in the
hospital so that is an enormous and and
terrible statistic and we're you know
this is inside a built environment so
what did the surfaces what did
buildings have to do with this pletely
is also sick building syndrome and
talked about for a long time some people
get sicker in certain buildings and
others what is the role the building
itself in or the conditions of the
building are the people inside that lead
it to have a lot more microbes
particularly fungi they can grow on
these buildings and you know there's a
lot of storm damage and other things so
we need to understand that and you know
frankly it's just a fascinating
environment and its own right when you
talk to building engineers we talk to
people really understand buildings
they're they're fascinating diverse
environments and they are worthy of
study in their own narrow molecular
methods so molecular methods have really
opened our eyes to the microbial world
it's been an explosion of information
and understanding that's certainly about
the human body there are also all
environments including the built
environment most of the microserver just
unknown much more than ninety nine
percent 99.999% have yet to be cultured
of any sort so we do not know how to
grow them on the plate which doesn't
mean they will never be grown on a plate
that's how we can learn a great deal
about them but they haven't been yet and
so to order to stun anything about them
you really need to get their genetic
sequence unclassified organisms there's
there's outrageous number of a
classified organisms that have been
identified only through a particular
marker gene namely the 16s ribosomal RNA
sequence now that we're expanding it
we're also using other parts of the
sequence and stitching whole genomes
together but it's still true that
there's many many groups of entire
groups and claims and microbes that are
only known through the 16s through a
single gene marker that we can get
through some of our molecular techniques
so there's a lot more to be understood
and what we can do is we can use the
unique DNA sequence patterns in this
gene and other genes within this gene
and other marker genes to ask several
very important questions who is there
who are they related to why are they
there and even where did they come from
and I'll show you some of the ways in
which we
able to do that all right so the
solution to not being able to grow them
all or it's a for a solution but to
still be able to study them understand
who they're closely related to and maybe
even their function is the fact that
they all have genetic material this is
kinetic material if you're talking about
bacteria and a lot of viruses also
things like archaea and fungi the
genetic materials DNA DNA is really easy
to work with it's easy and all DNA
behaves the same all the organisms may
all be different and growing different
conditions once you break open their
cells and extract their DNA it all
dissolves nicely and in water or other
ion on their solutions and then you can
study it very easily chemically and it's
extremely stable so what we're going to
do is take the antenna we tend to do is
we take an entire microbial of community
or assemblage and we break open all the
cells that's the first station first we
use chemically or mechanically shear
open the cells and the sub walls
releasing all the contents of the cells
once those are released we can purify
out the diamond get rid of the proteins
and the lipids leaving only this DNA or
RNA and then once we have the DNA
especially the DNA RNA to but you have
to turn it into DNA then you can take
out the DNA sequence and get all the
chemical letters using deep sequencing
approaches or otherwise these days deep
sequencing you're going to see my
earlier studies we cloned it in the
sequence length sequence tit which was
very tedious and now we can get the
letters of the sequences which work
wonderfully in computers because then
you can use the patterns of letters to
determine who's there so instead of
storing all this information we can just
store the letters of one strand of the
DNA sequence and put it in the computer
which is created storing these kind of
information and then we've used these is
sort of barcode if you want to put it
that way to type the species and figure
out who you're related to so for
instance down here on the bottom left
let's see if I can use one of these
devices video down to the bottom left
here
we see fast a file and here's a
particular sequence that we've grabbed
from the extraction of DNA in this
environment we sequenced it it came out
in our computer and we can use we can
use techniques such as blast or other
comparative analysis programs to ask
which book did it come from so r
instance this sequence could be this
particular organism in that environment
this sequence could be of this purpley
spiky organism here's another organism
as this sequence and the fourth one is
the sequence over here and we can
actually count the number of sequences
that come from a better of this type and
we can group them together and ask how
many are relative proportions of this
organism that in this particular
environment and do that for all the
organisms that we can get the sequence
one so it's a really effective way I
mean even just having these four
organisms would take a long time to
culture if there's a thousand organism
that you can just forget about the
culturing so the sequence information
becomes the primary way for us to
understand who's there ok so the methods
I'll just go over quickly the methods
I'm going to be using in this study
we're going to all the methods are based
on direct DNA extraction of microbial
communities the RNA comes out with I'm
not using any RNA techniques but RNA can
be used to study things like
transcription in the environment and as
well as RNA viruses I'm going to show
you some studies that are based on a
single marker gene sequence where we use
to serve primers to to amplify all the
same marketing from all of the bacteria
say in particular committee so it'll
amplify the 16s ribosomal RNA gene
sequence and because it's a conserved
primers to a site that they all have we
can PCR amplify it from all the bugs in
the acquirement and then we can send it
off for sequencing and then analyze i'm
going to using epic will also show you
some epi fluorescence microscopy where a
DNA and RNA a stain that actually
interpolates into cells and viral like
viruses or viral like particles and
allows you to visualize
without culture and count how many
bacteria and what we call viral like
particles there are on the slide and
then I also have data on shotgun
metagenomics which is like which is
instead of sick amplifying a single
sequence from all of the different
bacteria you take all the DNA cut it up
into little bits and sequence all the
fragments and then you can either
analyze the little fragments of DNA
separately or you can stitch them
together to try to get large context or
even whole genomes but it's a way to not
only look at the taxonomic profiles up
who's there but also the functional
profiles and we're done with all this of
course and we send it up to the Nerds
and give them some pizza and a few
skittles send it down into the basement
and get some analysis back about what's
going on right so the first part i'm
going to be reviewing some of my built
environment studies just go through a
history of it and i'll help you
understand hopefully a little but of the
why how we started it what it means and
what is useful for and i'll select a few
interesting stories based on both on 16s
loan libraries whoops musta see they're
both on 16s clone libraries and some
deep sequencing studies as it progressed
back in 2004 we had clone libraries and
it was just getting started with
next-generation sequencing so that's
what we used but it turned out to be
extremely effective just a little
tedious all right so I want to talk a
little bit about one of my favorite
early studies that I that was really it
says a lot about the built environment
but this is about a hospital therapy
pool that was where the lifeguards of
the pool were actually getting sick and
coughing up blood that sounds really
terrible so we suspected that they were
they were perfectly healthy life threats
of people in the pools weren't weren't
healthy that's why were there in the
pool in first place but the pool is
entirely contained indoors and it's warm
and a nice roughly body temperature has
got sick people swimming around it and
it couldn't chlorinate it like they
wanted to because the chlorine itself if
you sit there as a lifeguard would
actually damage
alums so we wanted to know I belongs to
the lifeguard so sort of a situation of
damned if you do damned if you don't
really anyway so what we did would I
work with an engineer and this is also
the pace lab we sample the sterile II
sampled both the air and the water of
the therapy pool we extract a DNA
directly from the water or the air
samples wasn't that easy and then we
pcr-amplified with this our universal
primers for the 16s gene and we
sequenced it sequence of coal markers
what did we find so this is a
complicated slide I apologize for this
but these are each pie charts here's an
example pie chart that comes from it
shows the phylogenetic diversity of the
organisms from a single sample in this
case this is a water sample DNA
extraction in fact b c d e and f were
all water samples or samples on the side
of the pool and you can see that there's
quite a bit of different phylogenetic
groups each one of these little pies
indicates the proportion that was gamma
proteobacteria by groups or other
bacteria or mycobacteria bingham bonus
bacteria and you know betta
Proteobacteria and so forth and what i
wanted to point out to you is the water
samples were really quite diverse and
highly variable but then we did the air
sample in the pool air we had a
completely other type of response that
it was entirely dominated by
mycobacterium and mycobacteria well
there is mycobacteria tuberculosis now
this wasn't tuberculosis didn't find any
but it turns out that other bacteria
mycobacteria live in the soil they
probably like to grow very nicely at 37
degrees and they're being enriched in
the air which is probably leading them
to get into the lungs of the laker so
they're not normally pathogenic by the
high enough concentrations some of them
can have similar effects and actually
cause lung problems if and ion
concentrations and we found a whole lot
of mycobacteria at 50 different species
that were
rich in the air in this one study almost
none of them had been culture so they're
all known by sequences that so very
interesting application of the method
another application of the method we use
was in the NICU newborn or neonatal
intensive care units I did one of the
first studies of this using culture
independent methods culturing that this
had been done for a long time but we
wanted to know how easy it was it to
find and what types of microbes will be
find on all of the surfaces that were
frequently touched by the staff and you
can see this NICU which is very much
like when we study there's loads of
people in there touching all the
equipment and going towards little
babies and this is an important area to
study because the little babies are
their immune systems aren't well
developed they have a lot of tubes in
their bodies and they're very sickly so
even even if it's not a pathogen
opportunistic infections are extremely
common and have devastating consequences
in requirements so we really wanted to
see what was there and how how many
different types of bugs were found in
this end so when we did the analysis
here's a breakdown of the analysis so
just quickly this is a principle
coordinates analysis of where each dot
here is a mathematical representation of
a particular sample from that we that we
sequence so this dot up here the blue
one we use this for instance getting
used to the technology okay sir ian said
that is a representation of the entire
bacterial community that came from a
single swipe sample on say one of the
computer keyboards that we were studying
from Nick you first NICU and the red all
the red dots come from the second engine
to interpret these plots you really have
to say if the dots are closer together a
community as a whole those two samples
their entire committees are more similar
to each other so for instance if you're
looking at these two samples they're
almost a cue pieing exactly the same
space their communities are highly
similar
so well first of all we found what we
didn't Alice's we found all sorts of
sequences that were closely related to
known opportunistic pathogens we found
evidence that were serious pseudomonas
streptococcus Staphylococcus and lots of
different bacteria we don't know they're
living or dead but it's but they were a
lot of them can survive for long periods
of time on dry surfaces but we also
found an interesting pattern that most
of the NICU of the two environments
broke down together but at one part and
one of the knick use the blue one we
found a lot of samples that were
completely dominated by intero bacteria
seen which are often known to be gut
bacteria so at some point in time we
feel that there was some kind of spread
of these intero bacteria AC and we know
there is a lot of diaper changing and
other things going on of course in this
office but all of the surfaces were
suddenly dominated by this group and
they really were different from the
other NICU and some of the other the
samples when the other NICU but also the
samples from the same computer then we
did another analysis where we took all
those samples and compared to all of the
known office studies or built
environment studies that we had at that
time this is another principal
coordinates analysis in
three-dimensional space and what you can
see and I know this is very complicated
i'll try to break it down easy is here
is the right here is this area most of
the studies it doesn't matter if they're
opposites nick use and restroom surfaces
all fall out into this this area here
but all of our NICU studies from that
one study are far away from all of the
other office and studies which means
this was a particularly interesting
event that happened only to this NICU so
this is a way that we can sell that
maybe deep sequencing approaches could
help us understand some event or
infectious spread that might
happen in side an indoor environment all
right airplanes so I also did a study in
fact I should point out that this in
this particular study of nikki's has
been followed up very nicely by some
other people who actually showed that
organisms within the neat newborn
intensive care units can actually
colonize newborn infants that are born
inside the hospital's through through
through c-section the c-section babies
can actually colonize by microbes that
are in the NICU all right so airplanes I
also did a study on airplanes where I
was able to sample several different
domestic and international flights
actually three domestic one
international flight and look at what
happens to the communities as you go
through so essentially before people
show up the whole airplane is really
nice and clean but then once these
people show up it gets really filled
with microbes very quickly I did for it
in the study at at four different sites
I did many swamps on armrest tray tables
and a lot of them in the laboratory so I
and each light I did I did repeat of all
this one internationally two domestic
slides I swapped I brought them back at
room temperature and I definitely
avoided alerting the TSA at that time it
wasn't a big deal and then I did the
clone library in the sequencing work and
what I found was almost all the action
oh sorry about that all the action was
taking place in the restroom every
surface in the restroom was contaminated
primarily by things like
propionibacterium Staphylococcus and
streptococcus and interestingly karani
bacterium was pretty prevalent and that
is associated with prostate infections
although I can't say that they're
causing prostate infections they may
have come from that but yeah the
laboratories were just covered even the
paper towels had significant evidence of
microbial diversity all right so now on
to a second part of mine
talk now that we know and we've known
this at a lot of studies now is repeated
consistently we really like to know we
know that microbes are on every surface
a lot of them are rotted by the humans
themselves all those also evidence of
environmental bacteria and one of the
main questions that wanted to know is
how fast do these assemblages actually
form how fast do you get this microbes
colonizing and even is there any kind of
ecological succession where you stir it
off with a certain kind of microbes and
then you end up with another all
together so in this seconds this study
then I'm going to concentrate on now
which is pretty recent I'm asked three
questions how quickly to assembly just
form how stable are they long term do
they go to the same place every time are
they always random and different and how
consistent are they in their composition
so how did that go by doing this well I
did this by I exposed on restroom
biodiversity so is all on the restrooms
i would say i hope i think it's going to
be similar to other environments but i'm
going to say this is a particular
restaurant here at the University and I
did a time series analysis of the
restroom biodiversity and I call it that
because I think biodiversity is usually
termed as an ecological setting where
organisms interact with each other it's
not clear that that's a case in indoor
environments because they might not they
might just be settling there and not
living together in the community unless
they're a true biofilm but sometimes I
think they might be but sometimes not
anyway that aside we looked at four
different restrooms at San Diego State
University to female on to mail em and
then we had too high and too low use so
the high was about ten times as many
people using as the low we sampled the
toilet seat the floor in front of it too
and a sub dispenser oh and I focus on
the floor in front of the toilet because
we ended up doing a lot of our work
there on future we did one time series
with all three and then we focus on the
floor for the rest of the study /
and we did repeated it the first we
repeated at once a week for eight weeks
the first time setting the first thing
we wanted to do though is to actually
find out to actually sterilize and
completely free it from all of the
microbes so we use eppley fluorescent
microscopy to actually ask what how many
microbes did we see on these services
and whether our whether we could get rid
of them to start completely from scratch
so what we want to do is say there is no
trace of microbes even DNA or RNA debtor
live on media services and then you
would start running the time series so
first thing we did with a sample each of
them did microscopy and you can see that
every surface is loaded with little
pricks of light the medium-sized ones
are bacteria they're very tiny pinpricks
of light are viral like particles and
then the giant ones are cells that could
be human opponent enjoy right so what we
did was here first thing was when we
sterilize them using ten percent bleach
and we actually had to we were testing
it at zero minutes two minutes and 20
minutes and by 10 to 20 minutes we had
we had no evidence of any we went from
lots of stuff to nothing and took about
at least 10 minutes and I think up to 20
minutes of just leaving it sit there to
completely eradicate all of the microbes
and viral particles so once we did that
we started running the experiment
alright and so the bottom so we ran um
we actually ran a repeated experiment of
how long it took to form this community
so it's not a true time series but
hopefully we do is we would with it we
would sterilize it let it go for eight
hours and then reefs and once we had
nothing eight hours sample despite only
eight hours we had perfect
correspondence to a study that was done
by Flores at all in 2011 on restroom
surfaces so what they found in 2011 was
that the soap dispensers the there was
clearly distinct communities between the
soap dispensers the toilet seats and the
floors and you can see this in this PCO
a plot printable
analysis all the ones who all be toilet
seat samples came together all the sink
samples are the hand soap dispenser
samples were our unit and all of the
floor samples were also always together
and this took eight hours to find the
same thing that they had which was had
developed over months and maybe years
they're clearly distinct communities and
surfaces and what's what was interesting
for the relator is that the floor had
the highest diversity of samples so we
concentrated so when we did a follow-up
study looking over an hour early time
point a very short period of time to see
how so eight hours we got a community
that might as well have been eight
months so we must have developed much
faster than them so we went back we
sterilize it again and we watched it
over the eight hours sampling every hour
and we only did the floor because of the
time so what happened when we sampled
every hour from eight nine ten eleven
twelve etc what happened to it well this
is what we have we actually had used a
source tracker program that I've
developed a few other people to ask
where the communities came from so that
the eight o'clock we sterilized at seven
we let it run to a I mean we
decontaminated thoroughly it's not the
sterilization we let it run to eight
o'clock and this is the proportion of
organisms from the different
environments that we found at eight
o'clock the mass majority were located
to fecal bacteria this is the the floor
in front of the toilet seat so this
makes a lot of sense then even though it
was on the floor skin bacteria we're
playing a fairly prominent role so about
twenty percent where skin bacteria and
then unknown outdoor and unknown were
the rest of it ten to fifteen percent
that stayed constant pretty much
throughout the time of experiment but
what you notice if it goes from eight to
nine a fecal bacteria are getting
smaller and smaller and smaller
proportion all the way down till about
three o'clock it looks as if it been
eight weeks
so by about three o'clock it right it's
fully the the diversity is about after a
few hours is this high and then it's
except the succession pattern happens
over the day and by 3pm it was might as
well have been eight weeks so it's a
really pretty rapid assemblage of
organisms and it happened faster of
course in the high-throughput a high
diversity restroom then below sorry the
high rising high occupancy restroom and
the low occupancy restaurant all right
looking at a different way you can see
that this is another way to the
successional trajectory over time in the
principal coordinates plot from I have
to find wrong all right this is the
successional trajectory and the
principal ordinance box looking at the
frequency and as it moves from zero
hours to eight hours and then over time
it reaches a peak that is slightly
different but very similar to the final
eight our time point so to get to the
final diversity takes longer but most of
it's already there all right this is
also an interesting part of the study we
found a clear separation of the these
are and other principal warrants
analysis and the female and the male
restrooms so there's quite a bit a clear
distinction between the bacterial
diversity and female and male mushrooms
the split in the points is as clear as
it usually gets in these type of plots
and when you look at the individual
bacteria the relative abundance in
bacteria from these two samples you can
see that there's the female restroom
were done had a big dominance well it's
not a huge proportion but the things
that were really different between the
were lactobacillus which makes a lot of
sense and and then switch with the men
Rosa Berea was higher than with the
women I also noticed that the laude was
also different but it was really a few
species that were really driving this
change would also make make a lot of
sense the high and low usage was
so different not quite as distinct there
is a high usage in red and the low usage
in blue down at the plot there's pretty
good separation on PCO a plus and what
we found was that if i look at the point
out here the bacteria's was higher in
the high usage rather than the low usage
plus rectory IDs is associated with
fecal samples and noah and era Pisco
beginnings ism areas sip to kc e is also
known as a gut organism and it tended to
be much higher in the high usage than in
the low usage things probably because
the anaerobic bacteria DS probably dies
out pretty quickly leaving only the skin
bacteria left because in anna room and
it doesn't survive an oxygen but if
you're constantly having people come in
and use the facilities then they're
going to be refreshing it with papal
bacteria quite consistently whereas in
the low usage they tend to die out more
and skin bacteria dominating we also
sound thinking of monas were different
and higher in the high usage and those
tend to be water living organisms so
when you're when you're doing a lot of
usage of the restroom water from either
the toilet I know it's disgusting but
that's how it is or from the sinks is
probably being sprayed around a lot more
in that particular environment all right
I also have some data on viral
abundances and and diversity this is a
on the top here I have sorry about the
peak religion but it's the opposite on
the top here the Shannon diversity we
saw went up from 8 9 10 11 12 so that
the richness of the community is
steadily increasing in terms of the
bacteria over time and then in we also
looked at the viral abundances versus
the bacterial abundances and we found
that there was a tight correlation
between the viral the amount of bacteria
in the surfaces and the viruses by or
like particles when you're doing the
counting interestingly enough though in
nor many environments the viruses are
ten times as numerous as the
bacteria summon oceans or in living
systems the viruses are actually more
abundant than bacteria but in our
situation the viruses were the ratio of
viruses and bacteria was point four to
one which is a really low ratio and it
does indicate that the dry surfaces are
not very actively putting out the
viruses aren't very active on these
really dry services we looked at the
shotgun metagenomics one of the things
that jumped out at us with the viruses
especially the DNA viruses associated
with not only bacteria the bacteria
[ __ ] but also the human viruses and
what we found were two groups of
organisms including the herpes viruses
herpes all over the restroom right
actually I just found this in when I was
in Germany recently they had a whole
public campaign about going to the
doctor if you if you had some you know
infections herpes infections and support
so you don't see these kind of
advertising in America Briana other was
quite amusing anyway the herpes viruses
are where we're all over the restroom
and I'm not exactly sure what they were
there's a bunch of different families of
herpes viruses but we also found a lot
of HPV herpes are human papilloma
viruses all over the restaurant most of
them were skin and wart causing these
are plantar warts or skin work herpes
cluding a lot of them had no had not
been cultured or identified and that's
really interesting and personally
because I've had a kidney transplant a
few years back and it turns out that
people have had kidney transplants are
very susceptible to getting skinned to
getting works and planted works probably
because their immune systems are so
suppressed so it's understanding that
the viruses and herpes virus is it hurt
HPV viruses are everywhere makes me
think again about wearing flip-flops
every time I go in the restroom right so
the last part of the talk I wanted to go
over with the part about microbial just
a title microbial dispersal but it's
really about some of the
software methods that we've used to
figure out who essentially where the
microbes came from that are
contaminating built environments or
practically any environment and so we've
been to this method call that's based on
bayesian statistics called it's a
bayesian community-wide culture
independent microbial source tracking
and the other title is where did that
schmutz come from and this is what it
does so the inspiration for it was the
indoor environments DNA surfaces of when
you look at the bacteria that are on
surfaces say for instance in the state
care study that i did it was a mixed bag
of bacteria from different sources you
can just look at the species in your
knew that somewhere from soil like
bacillus summer fecal bacteria other
with skin propionibacterium for instance
and then there are other ones we didn't
know where they're from so obviously
they're from not a single environmental
source this really don't grow naturally
on children's tables or on these
surfaces but they're there nonetheless
and they had to come from somewhere so
what a question was what are the sources
and how much does each source contribute
to the entire community so the question
is where does that schmutz come from not
first it's not native to a sample it
didn't grow their second it's mixed
likely multiple potential sources so we
came up with a a posterior a test that
use compared the sample data set we had
two other sample data sets from other
sources so for instance we have a indoor
environment and here's a skin one we're
comparing two and it's a fetal one and
here's the soil one and here's something
else and we even had an unknown one that
we didn't we could say we don't know
what these on but we can use it to
determine the source of the
contamination and also practically track
environmental contamination of the
movement of microbes so the Bayesian
approach takes a Bayesian models as
uncertainty about known and unknown
source environments and use a good
sampling procedure to sample whether to
create the distributions of where
so your sample X is considered a set of
intact so which each one can be assigned
to a source environment of some sort so
you have to have the source environment
and this is the paper if you want to go
into more detail on them and here's a
more an easier sample so let's say we
have an office desk that's art we're
going to call that our sink community
and our sink community is composed of
bacteria from all sorts of sources
including my hands when I touch the
surface here and then we compare the
sequences and that we got on from that
Sikh community to a bunch of other
samples from other studies or even our
own if you want to sequence that that
could be contributing to that
environment so for instance skip we get
a skin sample a mouse sample a good
sample with soil sample and then we
leave a spot for it well we don't know
where it's from and we ask what
proportion came for the skin what
proportion came for the mouth gut oils
etc we could also do this with other
things if we have a sink community of a
contaminated water source or anything
else we can say well which to the
comfort it to come from cow poop or bird
poop or human or sheep is its human
sewage to contaminate it and that's also
a useful way to another use of the
sovereign yeah sense and sense it was
contaminated food we'd really like to
know did it come from some farm where
they had cows or what all right so
here's a outline from the paper that
showed us how we can get this data for a
particular environment and this was used
to ask in the we use this in the
restroom study and I'll show you an
example here is this is really fun this
is our lab contaminated lab pcr water
that was making amplifications of
bacterial sequences when it shouldn't
have and we found that in fact most of
the higher proportion of it came from
gut sequences so somehow somebody had
contaminated from gut microbiome of
bacteria of our people bacteria somehow
got in the PCR one that was actually
sent with a kit I'm not going to tell
the nan fracture and then some of it was
skin
and a little bit of what was unknown
here's the NICU the Newton newborn
intensive care unit most of this was
actually contaminated from I'm going to
use the little markers here the red
indicates that most of that came from
skin so that makes a lot of sense
because people are constantly touching
this environment although it was a fair
amount of unknown in the sample as well
and then the office phone again a lot of
it is going to be skin bacteria and we
found that fifty percent of this
particular sample was skin where another
interest in ladakh was from about twenty
percent came from soil bacteria with the
rest from an unknown source alright so
it's a very useful technique for
understanding how things develop on
where they come from in the built
environment or is it turns out many
other environment you can also be used
to the method can also be used to
determine species frequencies so how
many of which kind of bacteria are our
part of that environment and I'll give
you an example of this so in the NICU
Aras to the office study actually the
office study we can tell you that this a
lot of it was skin bacteria and that
skin bacteria primarily we said it was
good bacteria because this
propionibacterium that makes perfect
perfect sense we also had we get another
instance of the red here was us we can
actually not only tell you where it
comes from but what bacteria is
representative that particular
environment in this case soon amonos is
a big player but in the NICU for
instance and taro bacteria from the skin
was was a big player that said it was in
fact it was located for skin for some
reason right and since then has been
used a lot I've been really happy to see
this been used in a lot of publications
that go way beyond the built environment
so for instance there was a it was used
in a microbial signature to look at
fecal pollution in Michigan it was used
to
ask if cohabitating family members share
microbiota with one another or their
dogs it was used to look at in a
longitudinal analysis published by Jack
Gilbert and colleagues about looking at
humans in the indoor environment so how
they contributed it over time it's been
used in intensive care units because it
turns out that newborn intensive care
unit the microbes from the guts of
newborn neonates and the intensive care
unit actually resemble those in the unit
resemble those found in the infants
themselves and it actually was also used
to show that in a mouse study that
bacteria which direction the back
microbes from moving from one Mouse to
another because we knew one was the
source and one was the same all right
and then in the next stage we're working
on making it not only work with the 16s
data but all sorts of other data which
I'm really excited about for instance
where we're going to use it we're going
to use right now it works with 16s data
but we're going to adapt it for shotgun
metagenomic data as well we're hoping to
do it expand the methods who can also
use with chemical methods like mass spec
and we're trying to make it work not
only on bacteria but also viruses and
fungi so source tracker can be used with
all of these things to track potential
sources of contamination all right and
the idea is that we're going to get some
greater specificity more unique
signatures and more biological insights
by using many more socials of
information than a single marker gene
study alright and for acknowledgments
here's my collaborators there's somebody
I have to think I put a set on but i do
want to especially thank Terri Schwartz
for doing all of the work on the
restroom study because that was a big
part of this and the sampling UCSD
Hospital scsu and the funding from the
Clorox corporation and especially the
Alfred P sloan Foundation and they're
built environment program have been
instrumental in and in this world and my
research report and with that I'll take
any questions thank you all right and
thank you very much for your
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can so
dr. I do have one question here that's
cute for you can microbe rile
environments detected in traditionally
chlorinated pools growing salt water
based treated pools so sorry I I don't
know they tested that actually that's a
good question I I imagine that they
would not grow as well because of
osmotic pressure but we have not tested
the biofilms on saltwater pools my guess
is that that would be the salt water
would be very effective at keeping down
the bacteria but I'm not done that study
and that's actually pretty interesting
because we have some in the area I'd be
really really nice to be able to study
that to see if that was an effective way
of cutting down both the amount of
chlorine that's been used and the
bacterial loads themselves so that's an
excellent question alright even thank
you and this is going to be in response
to your hospital pool water and air
bacterial study have you done a
comparison versus a standard community
pool environment curious on how that
might have a differ in the especially in
the micro bacterial concentration I
not tonight I have no I've not done the
study wit and comparison I'd love to do
it need some money unfortunately the if
it's not my guess is that the the
community pools tended much colder
cooler temperature and they tend to be
chlorinated so when they chlorinated the
pool after we worked on the study the
bacteria levels link down tremendously
also if they were salt water so the
temperature difference I think the
mycobacterium love to grow at this
higher temperature but also open pools
would definitely be different than a
closed environment the high humidity and
and the lack of and the chlorine would
probably make a big difference but to be
honest I haven't I haven't done that
study all the ones we have seen San
Diego's in the outdoor well there's few
now is a few indoor community pools and
that'd be really interesting to the
experiment I think I'm going to propose
that Nexus thanks to the idea already
here and this is our last question that
we have time for for today and dr. is a
s or 14 s sequencing better for
bacterial identification I wet 8's I
think there's 16s and 18s so 16s
ribosomal RNA and is how they refer to
the small subunit ribosomal RNA gene
sequences that are in bacteria the small
sins and the 16s is a size marker of how
it runs on a particular gel it's from a
long time ago the 18s is the also the
small subunit ribosomal RNA sequences
but they are larger and they're from
eukaryotes like fungi and humans and
mice and all that entry's
so they're just a larger molecule and
it's the that particular marker gene the
ribosomal RNA is really great at telling
apart bacteria archaea and the 18s the
same market and also news for things
like fungi but it's not as for the fungi
it's not discriminatory at a very low
level so the sequences are very similar
to one another among fungi and you end
up using have to use another marker of
the internal transcribed spacer which is
between the biggest [ __ ] well it's
anyway it's yeah things between the 16s
and 18s markers to be able to identify
them so it's really good for bacterial
identification but it's okay for one
giant just doesn't tell you a very it
doesn't tell you species or even genus I
think it's more like a family level
we're really great thank you so very
much again and do you have any fun and
closing remarks that you like to have
yes thank you no I just like to
appreciate I appreciate the people
setting up this lab roots seminar and
the organizers the committee and thank
you for everyone who's attending and for
your are your really interesting
questions I appreciate it alright thank
you and with that I would also like to
thank the doctor for his time and his
presentation along with rad lab roots
for allowing this presentation as well
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December the
eighth you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to for that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time goodbye